– Also, das gibt maximal die Note Vier.
– Pff!
Ich will dich mal sehen …
– Kein Problem.
Pass auf!
– Ja, und runter!
– Ich krieg das nicht so gut hin.
Wahrscheinlich, weil ich
lange keinen Sport mehr gemacht hab.
Sport war früher mein Lieblingsfach.
– Ernsthaft?
– Mhm, deins nicht?
– Ne!
Meine Lieblingsfächer waren
Deutsch und Geschichte.
– Oh Gott!
Die mochte ich überhaupt nicht.
Wahrscheinlich, weil meine Lehrerin mir
immer schlechte Noten gegeben hat.
– Wahrscheinlich hat sie dir
schlechte Noten gegeben,
weil du schlecht warst.
– Ich konnte Naturwissenschaften
immer ziemlich gut:
Physik, Bio,
Chemie …
Mathe!
Aber Deutsch und Geschichte …
– Ich fand Mathe immer superätzend!
– Ich find das hier superätzend.
Entschuldige bitte!
– Geht’s auch ein bisschen leiser?
Manche Menschen wollen arbeiten!
– Also wenn ihre Laune
nicht besser wird,
dann ... dann zieh ich aus.